Hello everyone, this is Frankie Freitas and welcome to another week of Holo Talk for the week of April second, two thousand.
Uh, we continue our series of recordings that we made at the Center for the Holographic Arts of Arts in Long Island City, New York, and Michelle Roy once again joins me in the studio.
Hello, Frank, I'm already interrupting you.
This week our guest is Mary Harmon, and Michelle, you did the interview with Mary and basically you were there to find out information on why artists would choose to work in the field of holography.
And I think you were sort of like approaching it as a career, but as we found out as the evening progressed that it's just not a career choice, I guess, for artists to get involved compared to someone who won would want to get involved with commercial holography.
Right.
I think that um artists probably what what I got out of talking to Mary was that artists more so than a lot of other people when they think about, you know, their careers is that art is a passion for them and it's something that they really can't even control because she talks about how, you know, even as a child she was, you know, sketching and drawing and painting and so forth.
In fact, she her career was uh that she was a nurse.
Um then art was just something that you know consumed her more and more and and so now that's become you know her life.
I don't think it's uh just unique to holography though.
I imagine with photography commercial photographers, just like you have commercial holographers and I would imagine anyone who would want to approach photography or any of the other arts would find out that it's it's a very hard career path.
Oh yeah.
Well and I think a lot of it has to do with, you know, just the money.
I mean you have to be able to support yourself somehow.
So um she talked about that, that that was not something that you know she needed to have a way to pay the bills and that's what you know being a nurse was about.
But you know, the art is sort of what feeds her soul.
Yeah, on the flip side of that on the money issue, it's a very expensive field traditionally to get involved with, but fortunately with the advent of the semiconductor diode lasers, I would think that uh we will start to see more people have the ability to get involved with holography.
And artists having more of an ability to manipulate the technology themselves because I think, you know, Mary talked about how at the beginning she was having other people, you know, do the the shots for her, but then she slowly is starting to get more involved.
But I think with the the uh laser diode technology that you're not as intimidated by, you know, there isn't this enormous you know laser and it's not as expensive to an investment that you have to make in order to to start experimenting and playing around and learning the skills and the techniques.
So the work that she had there I think was dedicated to her mother who had recently passed away and I found that interesting because just about two weeks before that you produced a a hologram here in the lab.
That was a piece from your mother which is basically just about the same right my mother died um when I was two and a half and my grandparents had sent me a few years ago a number of things that had belonged to her.
So then when we talked about me making a hologram and what what I make a hologram of I went looking through her things to see if I could find something because I wanted to you know sort of be able to have a another kind of recording of you know her and and it's a piece of her.
So you which is very similar to what Mary did.
Yeah we had spoken a little bit about combining that hologram with other elements as well which was right up.
Which is right, yeah which is what Mary did, yeah.
So we weren't copying Mary.
Speaking of which that piece that you did will be on display down at the Smithsonian and we're going to be down there are two dates.
One is April twenty ninth.
That's not open to the public.
That's actually National Teachers Conference.
But the day that will be open to the public will be May sixth.
And we would like to invite Holo Talk listeners who are in the I guess the Northeast corridor really to come down to the Smithsonian.
And we're going to have a number of different holograms on exhibit, especially the diode holograms because basically this is going to be at the Hershawn Museum, which is an art institute there as part of the Smithsonian.
And one of the things that we want to push is the fact that because you know holography was such an expensive medium to get involved with for so many years a lot of artists just didn't want to make the investment of doing that.
But now we couldn't make the investment.
Exactly.
But now it's uh well within the realm of I'd say motive I mean that's a relative thing, you know, whether someone can afford something or not.
Yeah but it's sixty bucks Frank to you know get your whole setup together.
So you know I think start out with shoebox yeah.
And then to move up to the more powerful diosors you're still only looking at around two fifty, two seventy compared to thousands of dollars previously so hopefully we'll be able to allow people to have that realization that holography is now not something that's out of reach anymore.
And uh let's start seeing people get involved right and be able to experiment more with it as well.
Yeah exactly because they you don't have to go through all that hassle and expense.
Yeah.
So uh yeah I was just going to invite people to come down and we will be doing presentations throughout the day and we're going to put a web page up I think it may be finished this weekend where you can get more information.
Look on the HoloTalk page for uh information on our Smithsonian presentations.
Click on that link and then it will take you right to the page to get more information.
And if you're a Holot listener who comes down let us know.
Or come up.
We would love to you know know that you're someone who listens to the show and um be able to get a chance to to chat with you.
All three of you.
Well that way we won't be overwhelmed.
Anything else you want to add before we move on to the sorry I didn't mean to cut in like that that's it I'm done okay thanks for tuning in to hall talk see you next week bye okay we're back with the show and we're sitting here or I'm standing Michelle is sitting and we're here with Mary Harman who has a number of uh beautiful white light reflection holograms in the show image plane uh work uh could you tell us a little bit about the work uh did you have a certain theme that you were working with or uh anything that's special about the work itself.
Great I um I brought the work uh the ideas I brought into the to the Hollow Center originally I wanted to do still life because I I'm a painter and I was painting um uh I paint very realistically and was doing some um what I call the Vanita series based on the Dutch still life paintings.
So that was one idea.
I thought well I want to do some still life and I set up a few things for that.
But the other idea I had was a lot more personal and it had to do uh with uh oh uh I wanted to recreate a time in my life and that was my first community went in 1950.
And this all came about over the last few years.
I've been working on this uh my mother was sick and uh died of cancer probably about the same time I think she died just when I put the proposal in and then I took some of the objects from her from her house and made holograms of it.
I really just wanted to document some of these objects and it turned into something a little more I think over the year I've been working on it and finally finished most of the installation this uh just about a month ago and it's it's I think it's still growing a little bit.
I don't know if you've you've caught that.
I I didn't write a lot about where this stuff all came from.
I didn't want want that yet.
Um and that's about it.
So I got two series going in this and the Still Lives and the and what I call the first communion project.
Uh which I think yet is gonna get bigger.
I've done some paintings with it as well which we didn't have uh space to show but uh but uh I can see doing a a whole room of the holograms uh some more boxes and uh maybe some of the real objects as well and the paintings.
Did you produce all the works here at the center?
Oh absolutely absolutely so what um the artisan residency they accepted my proposal and then we did all we made all the masters here during the residency.
And then um I we we did that over three days and then I came back later and did the transfers.
So so D uh Dan and and uh Anna Maria did all the technical work as well which I mean you can see the quality and that's Dan's Dan's influence there and I mean they're really they're bright.
They're the really the brightest holograms I think I've ever uh ever produced.
They're very bright and clean.
Did you do any of the processing darkroom work?
Um no I I'm just curious what processing technique you use for them because they're so crystal clear and they are very bright.
And they're on AGF materials so we're we're starting to get used to seeing brighter results on the Slavic and HRT materials but I'd say that the shot shots that you have out there can compare to anything that's been done on those materials on the ACFA.
Um part uh we weren't quite sure.
Just things were just working right.
Uh we we seemed to get the exposures right and the the masters were so bright and I always thought it was the choice of objects I used.
Do you notice I used a lot of glass?
Uh mirror I this is the first time I played with mirror, I didn't know what was gonna happen.
Whether the whether the pulse the light was gonna bounce off and ruin our uh image completely, and it didn't.
It just everything just got sharp.
Those little figures, uh there's one figure in there that's made out of uh uh clay and it's sort of a pinkish color, and that seemed uh I don't know, it held the light or something.
I don't know.
And and all the reflections, the reflective material, it um it worked a lot better than than we thought.
It was that who knows.
There was there I th that old word again, there was a magic here when we uh we were shooting and it was like we couldn't do anything wrong.
You mentioned a pulse.
Are they pulsed work?
Oh, there are pulse.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
We didn't set anything up on no to do the masters Why did you choose to do that with uh inanimate objects?
Just out of curiosity, use a pulse laser.
Um I don't know, I'm just you know Well is that's question?
No, it's it's quick.
You know, I mean you ever see when you set up uh inanimate objects, you know, we're talking a couple of days uh setting up and hot gluing.
I mean, man, we just set these right up in front shot.
There's there's our first master, you know.
We were doing a couple masters, three masters a day.
I came up with ten masters in in three days.
And do you have a studio of your own as well?
No, no, no.
I uh I got into when uh well I've always I I first in nineteen eighty-five, my first experience with holography, I was in Toronto and um uh Michael Soudon did some of my images.
So I always paid the technicians to do my work.
It was with the fringe research.
That's right.
Fringe research, yeah, way back then.
And um then I worked with Michael Page, Ontario College of Art, but basically all the time I uh paid people to do my work for me.
Melissa Crenshaw in Vancouver.
Uh ran at Doris Vila's lab one summer.
So by the time I you know, after a few years of getting other people to do my work, I wanted to learn to do holography.
So I took some courses, did dance course, and uh then did an artist in residency at the museum here.
It was my first time doing holograms on my own.
It was great.
I mean I just and then I ran at Doris's lab one summer and just did nothing but from uh dawn till dawn, shot my own work for the first time.
Dor Doris works a lot with white light transmission work.
Did you do reflection work there or did you work uh white light transmission?
Totally reflection.
I've never done uh white light transmission um uh y for whatever reason.
I don't know, maybe just to limit I wanted to really limit uh what I what I was doing because I didn't know anything, you know, so I'll just hone in on one thing.
Plus I like I I've always I like doing objects.
I do real objects and uh and um I want I I like that physicality that they give me.
Even though your your depth, you know, so so what you got ten inches of depth to play with.
So I like those limitations too.
Well, what can I come up with that, you know?
So um start using a diode laser, you'll get more depth in that.
Oh yeah?
I'm gonna I'm gonna turn the microphone over to Michelle Michelle have a few other questions here.
Yeah.
We'll s we'll see, you know, I'm I'm open.
I I w it was so exciting.
This is the most I I didn't do work since ninety n I think ninety one or ninety two, I worked in Doris' lab and I haven't done holography since.
And when I put in this proposal I I was I've been painting.
I thought I'm not gonna do holography anymore.
I don't have any money to do holography.
You know, that's what uh I never worked on film.
What am I gonna do?
You know, they they don't make us glass plates anymore.
So this was just wonderful to be working in it again, you know.
I've got that old Wow, creativity.
You know, this is the most creative medium you can work in, you know.
It's it's like everything's wide open.
It's still so do you uh now you you you're a painter.
Um which would you I mean, is there are there certain things that you can express through your painting that you can't through holography and certain things that you can express through holography that you can't through your painting.
I mean, how does that go together?
Yeah, yeah.
No, they're not they're not compatible.
I've tried.
Um, you know, the best I could do, I painted the tape on those boxes, you know, a little trompeau on that.
But other than that, I've tried to put a painting next to a hologram and uh it's two different mediums.
Do you find that you're doing different kinds of work in holography as opposed to what you do in your painting?
Um I mean I know you talked about the realism in your painting, uh but you know, do you find that you're you're trying to express different things?
D do you know what I'm saying?
Um Well, it's it's just it's two it okay.
One holography is sculptural.
Holography is three dimensional.
Painting is two dimensional.
I mean start with that.
I mean and with the with uh when I'm trying to paint realistically, I'm trying to make a two dimensional surface appear to be a three dimensional surface.
So when I got a hologram, I got a three I got three dimensionalities.
So so so my f my aim is different right away, right?
So uh so what do I do with the hologram?
Then I have to play around with with its own characteristics which is transparent you know, transparent fleeting image, you know.
And to me it's always three dimensional so uh yeah, it's just totally different.
But what what I'm saying I think I I talk about the same things I think.
I think I I do um I talk about you know, death, life yeah.
Pretty well that but uh uh in pain I mean I can paint anything.
I can you know I can do a landscape in in painting, I can do a huge painting of a very realistic landscape.
I'm not about to attempt that in holography.
D how are the what what made you dec what attracted you to wanting to do holography?
I mean, obviously you were attracted to the medium itself and having other people do it, but what made you decide I want to do this, you know, what what got you, you know, hooked on it if you will.
I was I've always worked with illusion.
I mean to me that's what painting is, right?
It's it's dealing with like I said, making a two-do something appear something different.
And I was um trying to s at one point I was trying to suspend some objects in the air and somebody said, Hey, did you ever see a hologram?
This is you know, again, eighty five show in Toronto and I was just blown away.
Here were these little objects that were floating there.
And it was so it was a sculptural element of it that uh I could I could that I could make an object that floated in air, you know.
And that was that was about it, you know, and and m pretty well nothing else at the time.
It's nothing to do with painting or what else I was doing.
What what do you enjoy about working in holography?
What is it that appeals to you?
Um that that m makes you come back for more obviously it's not the money because you said there's no money in it, but what is it that appeals to you about it?
Both both in terms of you know how it lets you express yourself but also um just in uh you know, physically working with the medium because it's very different, I would assume.
I I'm not an artist myself, but I would assume that it's very different to paint than it is to, you know, work in holography just, you know, even physically.
You know, I part of it is that I never know what's what it's what the final outcome's gonna be, you know.
I you can plan it and uh and and it's okay, put it that way the process.
You know, when I I c I bring in a model, I set it up on the table and and you see something you know that you never anticipated.
Something happens and then I can start changing something.
So it's a creative process basically.
And uh um that's that's the exciting part.
I mean, even when I c I come away with no I came away with images.
So I had a doll, I had a lamp, I had these holographic images.
What the heck am I gonna do with them?
I mean, so it it doesn't end when I make an image.
Then I take them all home and I think, okay, now what can I do with these things?
I start putting I keep the images transparent, I start putting things behind and uh it's uh you know the process continues.
It's it's just this wonderful long creative process.
I can do a lot of other things with these things now.
You know, I I don't necessarily I'm not stuck with that just that thing and now if if someone were um thinking about wanting to, you know, get into um not just even not just philography but you know being an artist in general um you know how what w what kinds of words of encouragement would you give them or what what kinds of things would you tell them to to be thinking about um in terms of considering you know art as a career.
Expect to make a lot of money right you know I mean I I think it's I I don't see it as something anybody would ever say I'm going to be an artist, you know.
I think that's something that comes with with l experience of of life, whatever.
I mean it's I would encourage a younger person you wanted to do this well I always drew my father was a painter.
My you know we all we all were good with our hands.
Yeah but I did other things.
I I I trained as a nurse.
I worked for years as an RN.
Really?
Oh yeah.
I worked in ICU up until um ninety ninety one, you know what made you make it she you know I mean are you you're not still I I worked to support my art.
You know, it's as simple as that, you know but at the same time I was involved in life.
You know, I mean I wasn't just making art.
I mean I was I was involved in doing something else.
I can't just I can't just paint or just you know that's I mean I you know I mean read read history, read you know, read poetry, read literature, do something you know do something your creative soul sort of thing.
Art comes from right experience.
Yeah.
Uh no, I I've uh I've always I've always you know had some kind of job or something in in in that ground maybe grounded me.
I don't know what the word you want to say.
I mean I had kids, I had uh you know, I d I've always done other things.
Right now I've you know, got a little cabin up in up in Quebec that I'm just wanting to get back and do the finish of shingling I started last summer, you know.
I mean that's I love working I love working with tools.
I took a carpentry course once when I got tired of nursing and I was just gonna do renovations.
I mean that's I have to get away from the art, you know.
It's like I'd I I'll go out there and hammer and work on something, work on a project, I'll do diplumbing.
I d I I like doing all that stuff.
And then the art'll come.
You know?
I don't sit there and try and think of ideas to do art, you know.
A lot of the earlier holograms I did I think were just to just to get to get the release of some of the stress I had working ICU.
I mean I did a lot of stuff about death, little ghosts, I had little ghosts floating through things.
They were all dealing with my experiences working as a nurse.
I do you think that was are you glad that you had those experiences that they sort of gave you that Oh yeah, I mean, yeah.
I mean I I c I could never see myself as just doing art.
I mean I I never really went to art school uh in I mean I did, I went a couple of years to a place in Toronto called Art Sake when I was already in my late thirties.
And I thought, well I'll just I just wanted to go to learn to paint, you know, but I never really learned to paint.
What I learned was there were a lot of other people in the world who felt like I did that had a passion for uh for for this stuff, you know.
I'd never been I'd never been in an art gallery until I was a senior in high school.
I went on a class trip to Washington DC and I saw um uh Dolly the last the crucifixion hanging in Washington DC.
So surrealism, right?
You know I mean that was Magritte, all these guys you know.
I mean I this was all my maybe my father's influence too, you know.
He was uh uh Flemish.
Oh okay.
My dad was a Flemish painter.
So he was he was born in Ghent and he painted.
Really?
Yeah.
So it's there's genetic there too.
You know, we c we were all good eight of us we were all good with our hands.
Yeah.
Well this has been very interesting.
I've learned a lot.
I really appreciate it.
I don't know if you have any more questions for Mary uh Frank but any additional shows coming up anywhere this is going to uh travel to another location after it's finished here, right?
Uh we're bringing the show in two weeks to uh Fort Myers, Florida.
Can't remember the name of the gallery, Zaizi something anyway.
And then it's going to Tucson, the Contemporary Museum of Art uh for six weeks.
That's uh starting May twel uh was that right yeah May twelfth.
It'll be in Tucson for six weeks.
And I'm very excited about that 'cause I got a big space.
And I think the curator at Tucson Museum was a former student of dance.
Oh okay.
So nice holographic connection there.
He knows what the medium's about, which is it's nice to see this work starting to go to contemporary museums.
I'm hoping to get something going in Montreal at the um uh Museum des Art Contemporary uh too.
I'm hoping that that'll I'd like to do a big installation combining holography and painting and that just start getting the stuff into the contemporary art galleries forget the group forget the group science science tech shows and start getting holography scene in the right venue.
It really is important.
What do you think the biggest drawback is for people to get involved with holography?
Is it the initial cost that they have to put out for an investment to start?
That's certainly that's well you know I yeah exactly.
Um it's not like going and buying a bunch of paints at the art store.
It's getting more so boy cost of brushes try and get some good brushes anymore.
But uh you know I mean there's opportunities for anybody to take weekend courses.
That's how I did it.
I took a you know I wanted to learn about holography.
I took a weekend course at Fringe Research.
You know?
It was enough to get me going and then I applied for an artist in residency there.
And I got it.
You know I didn't have any uh I didn't have any I didn't need money to start.
I just needed some good ideas and learn how to write up a good proposal.
Hone your ideas.
Do photographs first.
You know, do a professional job with this stuff.
When you put a proposal in do it well.
That's the whole c care.
That's that that okay there's a nice thread between my nursing, between my art, between the way I paint, you know take care.
Do it you know do it professionally.
Take care with what you do.
Love it.
And just love what you do, the pieces.
Yeah.
That's a great way to stop.
Well thank you Mary.
You're welcome.
Thank you.